Welcome back.
So we're on problem number 15.
Boy, this SAT can be tiring.
I know you probably rolled your
eyes when I said that
because you're the one that
has to take it, not me.
Anyway, number 15.
The graph above shows-- and this
is on page 399-- shows
Alena's height in inches.
So the graph looks like this.
And then I'll draw the
rest. I don't have to
draw these fancy lines.
You get the point.
So this is her age.
Let me do it at 6,
8, 10, and 12.
And then when she's 6,
she is 45 inches.
This is in inches.
So at 6 she's at 45.
At 8 she's at 50.
At 10 she's at 55-- no, a little
less than-- well, this
is like-- on the graph
it looks like 55.
And the way they draw it, it's
like a little bit lower than
55, so it's like a little bit
lower than 55 on the graph.
And then at 12, she's
right at 60.
And then they draw a line
connecting all of them so it
looks something like this.
So the line looks like
this, like this.
It's nothing fancy.
And it says Alena's height at
age 12 was what percent
greater than a height
at age 6?
So when she is 12,
age, height.
So at age 12, she's what?
At age 12, she's
60 centimeters.
That's this point, right?
60.
And at age 6 she's what?
45 centimeters, right?
Age 6, 45.
So this question is really-- so
we've got to make sure that
we're reading right.
Alena's height at the age of
12 was what percent greater
than her height at
the age of 6?
So they're really saying 60 is
what percent greater than 45?
And so I actually do this
all the time in my job.
I work in a hedge fund.
But this is what I
do all the time.
And a really quick and dirty way
of doing this, you would
literally say, well, this is the
same thing as 60 divided
by 45 minus 1 to get you the
percentage, because-- well, I
don't want to confuse
you too much.
But 60 divided by 45
will tell you what
percentage 60 is of 45.
So 60 divided by 45 is what?
It's 1 and 15/45, or
1.333333, right?
I think you can confirm that.
So that equals 1.333333.
Or 60 is 133% of 45.
We can make all of
these statements.
60 over 45, that's a percent
that 60 is of 45.
That's 1.333333.
It keeps repeating, right?
Repeating.
But they want to know what
percent greater than her
height at age 6.
So 60 is 133% of 45.
This is the same thing as
saying that 60 is 33%
greater than 45.
Hopefully, you understand
what I'm saying.
Saying one thing is 133% of
another thing is the same
thing as saying that this
first thing is 33%
greater than 45.
Or we could say that saying
something 133% is equal to 33%
more than 100%, right?
More than 100.
I hope I'm not confusing you.
I try to do this in a couple of
different ways to help you
understand what 33%
greater means.
If x is 33% greater than y,
that means x is 133% of y.
So they want to know how much
greater is 60 than 45?
Well, it's 33% greater.
And so the answer is C,
33 and 1/3, because
it's a repeating 33.
Next problem.
This looks fun.
So we have this cylinder
looking thing.
Let's see how well I can
draw a cylinder.
Well, my cylinder's going to
be a little tilted, but you
get the point.
I should have drawn these
vertical lines first. This is
the cylinder.
So that's the cylinder.
And they're saying that on the
base of the cylinder, we have
this line x, or this
distance x.
It goes to the center.
It's essentially the center
of the cylinder.
Let me draw it in a more muted
color to show that's it's in
the inside, and the height of
the cylinder goes to the top.
They're essentially asking which
of the following-- and
they give you a bunch of
choices-- has the same volume
as the cylinder shown with
radius x and height to x?
So they're saying this is x,
that's x and this is 2x.
So before figuring out which of
these choices has the same
volume as this thing, let's
figure out what the volume of
this thing is.
Well, if you know the area of a
circle, you essentially know
the volume of a cylinder,
because it's really the area
of one-- you can kind of figure
out the area of this
base and then just multiply it
times the height, right?
Multiply it times this third
dimension of the height.
So what's the area
of this base?
So volume is equal to area of
the base, which is pi times
the radius squared, so
that's pi x squared.
And then we're going to multiply
that times the
height, times this, times 2x.
So the volume of this is
equal to 2x times this.
You get 2 pi x to the
third, right?
Because this is x to the first.
Add the exponents.
So volume is 2 pi
x to the third.
We know the volume
of our cylinder.
So let's see what these
other choices are.
So choice A says a cylinder with
radius 2x and height x.
So radius is equal to 2x and
the height is equal to x.
So what would this be?
The volume would be this squared
times pi times this
because we take the area of the
base, so the area of the
base would be what?
It would be pi times 2x squared,
and we multiply that
times the height.
And this equals-- I can already
tell you this isn't
going to be right because
we've got a 4 in here.
Oh, this is x, right?
The height is x.
So this will get 4 pi x to the
third if you multiply it out,
so that's not it, B.
A cylinder with radius 2 pi,
radius is equal to 2 pi x, and
height is equal to x.
And I can already tell you this
is going to be it because
we're going to get something
with a pi squared in it
because if you take the area
of the base, you get-- the
volume will just be pi times
2 pi x squared times x.
And we're going to get 4 pi
squared, and then you're going
to have another pi, and
it's 4 pi cubed.
It's not going to be the
same thing as this.
Choice C.
A cube with edge 2x.
This is easy.
If a cube has side 2x, it's
volume is just that side
cubed, right?
So volume would be 2x
to the third, and
that equals 8x cubed.
That's definitely not right.
D.
A cube with edge 2 pi x.
So the same thing.
The volume for this cube would
be 2 pi x to the third.
And this is going to be what?
8 pi to the third,
x to the third.
Once again, not right.
So assuming I haven't done
anything wrong yet, it's
probably going to be choice
E, but let's confirm.
Choice E.
A rectangular solid with the
dimensions-- ah, see this
looks very suspicious.
So let me draw the rectangular
solid.
A rectangular solid with the
dimensions x, 2x and pi x.
So we just multiply width times
height times depth.
So x times 2x times pi x.
You would get 2 pi x cubed.
And the answer is E.
Very good.
And you could have done that
faster just kind of inspecting
some of these earlier ones.
Anyway, I'll see you
in the next video.